hi there steve kaufman reporting on my
polish challenge i'm about halfway
through the 90-day challenge
uh i've had two sort of
slow periods one was when we had a
couple of friends visiting from sweden
and we toured british columbia so there
was
five six days with no polar study and
now i had my two sons visiting here in
palm springs they've gone home but
during that period i wasn't able to do
very much although whenever i was in the
car alone shopping or working out in the
gym with my two sons
i would listen
so i learned more and more about polish
history but i didn't have enough time to
do my linking either on the ipad or on
the computer
so i've fallen behind and i'm going to
start working hard again
um
you know i will start speaking maybe i i
said i would do it in early october i
think it will be second half of october
uh
i'm not that fussed about speaking i
have to be honest because there aren't
many people i can speak to here in
polish
um i am interested in
i'm listening to this
ceremony alert which is a book that i
read in english by bill browder about
his experiences in russia
and i'm listening to this
audiobook on polish history and at the
same time reading on polish history it's
not parallel text but a lot of the same
names and and the same vocabulary it
comes up in both so i'm i'm getting more
and more into polish i'm learning more
and more about poland all of that is
fascinating to me at some point i guess
i'll have to start speaking ultimately i
won't be good at speaking until i go to
poland which i hope to do maybe next
year
so that's all i have to report at this
time and i am going to do a question and
answer video as well which
is sort of a continuation of the one
that i did with mark last week
so work hard in your polish or excuse me
in your 90-day challenge whatever
language you're learning bye for now